l'année dernière vous présenter un
smartphone d'entrée de gamme que je
connaissais pas une marque qui étaient
nouvelles c'était la marque remy j'ai
testé le rytme de ça c'est le smartphone
de l'année dernière et là j'ai rencontré
à paris l'autre jour sur le lancement
européen et français
le readme trois pros qui est le nouveau
smartphone de rim hier je vous montrais
on va comparer avec celui de l'année
dernière d'ailleurs si vous n'avez pas
vu ma vidéo test je vous invite à aller
la visionner moi ce que j'ai trouvé cool
ce smartphone pour ce n'est pas une bête
de performance mais il y avait un vrai
boulot fait un vrai parti pris au niveau
du design notamment envoyé cette espèce
de défi relier ce qu'on avait qu'on a
toujours d'ailleurs sur le ring me2
niveau du dos je trouve qu'elle vende
beau travail de fait par la marque là
dessus est un produit qui était plutôt
pas mal plutôt intéressant si vous
voulez en savoir plus je vous invite à
aller voir la vidéo de test
hélas cette année remy arrive en europe
et demi c'est un leurre remy fait partie
d'un groupe et partait du groupe auquel
on retrouve au pot wyplosz entre autres
donc il ya un vrai savoir faire derrière
il ya un vrai connaissance du marché et
ils font partie de tous ces acteurs
chinois qui arrivent en france en europe
avec des produits très intéressants et
ça c'est un produit qui est hyper
intéressant pourquoi parce qu'il vous
propose un smartphone un tarif d'entrée
de gamme qui en réalité un smartphone
milieu de gamme plutôt pas mal avec un
socle intéressant c'est celui là c'est
le readme trois pros alors je voulais
montrer l'autre jour la présentation à
paris c'était plutôt cool
le smartphone geler la gelée testé je l'
ai vu un petit peu sous tous les angles
de tous les côtés et il est maintenant
venu l'heure leur venue je sais pas
pourquoi je bute sur cette mode en ce
moment c'est le moment de vous dire ce
que j'en pense
[Musique]
le truc est qu elle serait litres en pro
c'est le boulot qui est fait au niveau
du design alors vous avez un petit doigt
en plastique ça c'est pas complètement
dingue mais par contre vous êtes un vrai
boulot niveau de la finition c'est parce
que vous êtes vous en rendre compte
comme ça mais si elle se rapprocher vous
avez reçu 82 ligne avec un petit
dégrader plus sur le bleu qui arrive sur
le violine vous avez le branding sur le
côté ennemis en un smartphone qui est
assez joli de ce côté là et je vous le
dis à ma mère y avait déjà un bel effort
qui avait été fait enfin beau travail
qui avait été fait de la part de rim mis
sur le gril me2 avec leurs ennemis 3 qui
continue à faire un produit que je
trouve vraiment très sympa et surtout à
un tarif défiant toute concurrence
double module photo capture des
empreintes digitales au bon ça c'est un
peu classique mais une fois de plus sur
un smartphone qui positionne est un très
très très bas ça me paraît pas forcément
très très grave
votre bouton pour venir l'allumé pour
l'éteindre ici ce qui peut paraître
assez surprenant c'est le fait d'avoir
du micro usb surtout qu'on aide la
recherche extrêmement rapide message et
vous dire dans quelques instants le haut
parleur mono cayla la prise jack le
petit micro vous avez vos boutons de
volume ici votre tiroir de cartes sim
vous avez deux cartes sim également une
carte micro sd ici votre micro pour la
réduction de bruit
le petit haut parleur qui est située la
lac albert en phase avec la petite
goutte d'eau
and that's it en fait ce smartphone il
se concentre sur l'essentiel est ce
qu'on s'en fait d'avoir un écran
suffisamment grande bonne qualité
suffisamment bien contrastée avec des
couleurs assez naturel assez lumineux
seul cran de 6 3 pouces lcd avec une
résolution fhd plus il est bien il
fonctionne bien pour jouer à des jeux
comme publie sa marche vachement bien
faut pas se mettre en qualité graphique
et liez vous mettez en qualité graphique
basse mais ça marche bien c'est couvrir
des jeux comme ça vont tourner dessus et
c'est vraiment ça qui est intéressant
avec ce smartphone c'est que les poires
confites et d'un écran qui quand même
suffisamment france à l'écran 6,3 pousse
même si c'est du lcd
ça va plutôt bien il est vraiment d'une
bonne qualité stmicro qui est vraiment
très honnête vous avez en parlant mono
sur le côté qui fait bien la faire aussi
lorsque vous venez jouer à des jeux
comme ça et en plus en terme de
performance il vraiment vraiment correct
avec un snapdragon 510 c'est le sort que
vous retrouvez notamment sur le au port
hainaut qui coûte 499 euros alors que là
vous êtes sur un smartphone qui coûte
entre 249 euros et 199 euros autant vous
dire c'est vachement bien
on a soit 4 gigas de ram soit 6 giga de
ram soit 64 giga de stockage soit 128 j
de stockage et pour venir regarder du
contenu multimédia aussi je trouve ça
intéressant alors sa règle on a une
petite encoche on goûte d'eau sur le
côté on est dans l'écouté sur un
smartphone qui coûte pas forcément hyper
cher donc on peut pas tout avoir
vous avez aussi une bordure à droite qui
est quand même assez proéminente
mais une fois de plus sur un smartphone
ne coûte pas forcément très cher je
trouve que dans l'absolu c'est vraiment
bien le boulot d'autant plus qu'en terme
de jo vous avez un seul haut parleur
mono ici qui envoie franchement dubois
qui avançons qui est plutôt de bonne
qualité mais bien de les gold race qui
est quand même chamakh ont un aspect qui
as intéressant avec suffisamment de
pistes pour l'écouter comme ça ça va
le son est pas trop criard ça reste
vraiment correct ok cool sur ce
smartphone si vous avez une prise jack
qui est ici alors la prise jack elle va
vous servir effectivement bien profiter
d'une expérience audio qui sera un peu
meilleur que ce que vous allez pouvoir
écouter directement comme ça avec le
simple haut-parleurs mono ça marche bien
c'est sympa la qualité est correcte
il développe quand même pas mal de
puissance à on a quand même mais on a
quand même relativement pas mal de
puissance comme ça lorsque vous à
l'écouté au casque
en plus on inspecte qui est correct
c'est pas du tout le plus ouf mais ça
marche ça dépend par contre
effectivement de la qualité de votre
caste si vous avez un kart qualité que
quand même pas mal de pouvoir vous faire
plaisir pour la doc smartphones qui est
assez lumineux avec des couleurs qui
sont assez naturel assez bien rendue
avec des contrastes qui sont vraiment
correct qui est vraiment bien pour venir
jouer à des jeux pour venir regarder des
films des séries tout ce que vous voulez
tout ce qui vous fera plaisir qui en
audio n'a pas à avoir honte de lui tout
ce qui peut proposer c'est plutôt bien
le fait ou vont recevoir une prise jack
ça va faire plaisir à pas mal de monde
ça c'est aussi intéressant et surtout ce
qui est assez dingue variations ce
positionnement tarifaire c'est les
performances que vous avez derrière vous
avez le qualcomm snapdragon 710
normalement vous ne retrouvez pas là
dessus en plus ce smartphone il va se
poser en rival oshiro me remmy note 7
qui lui par contre un saut qui quand
même moins performants là avec un
snapdragon 710 c'est franchement très
très bien et très bien joué de la part
de rim mis sur ce positionnement
tarifaire
autre point qui est assez énorme et qui
sont vraiment l'apanage de ce smartphone
c'est l'autonomie vous avez une grosse
batterie de 4000 45 millions terrain
c'est assez bon on va pas se mentir sur
un smartphone d'entrée de gamme comme ça
par contre le seul point négatif c'est
la recharge vous avez uniquement de la
recharge en niekro usd c'est un choix
qui peut être dit
ici la comprends d'autant plus qu'on a
de la voûte charge 3.0 vous permet
d'avoir une recherche très rapide en une
heure en un peu moins d'une heure vous
allez leur charge et de 10 15% jusqu'à
100% extrêmement rapidement pourquoi une
connectique un peu old school
j'imagine que c'est pour des questions
du couac ça paie moins pour pouvoir
tirer un moment d'alba on a retrouvé
quelques moyens de faire des économies
et j'imagine bien évidemment que
derrière le micro usb
c'est quand même un moyen de faire
quelques menues économies c'est un
smartphone qui va se débrouiller soit
avec le capteur d'empreintes digitales
et qui va extrêmement vite pour le
déverrouiller comme ça soit avec falcone
l'homme qui marche aussi très très bien
c'est extrêmement rapide pratique bon
sens ça fonctionne parfaitement bien
c'est bien maîtrisée sait pas qui est
tout nouveau
mais qui mangent bien également là
dessus il tombe sur un colorant et si ce
qui est le tout nouvel os notamment de
au pot qui marche bien qui est sympa qui
est très pratique qui est assez
fonctionnel alors il faut s'y habituer
c'est vrai qu'on n'a pas forcément c'est
ses repères là dessus vous pouvez venir
il est opérateur des couleurs plus
chaudes plus froid je vous conseille de
venir réchauffer parce que par défaut il
est assez bleu vous venez de cas c'est
un petit peu comme ça c'est beaucoup
mieux après ya pas mal de petites
options différentes à venir marc bon c
c'est un choix avoir un on aime ou on
aime pas qu lors os ça c'est une
question de goûts et couleurs on va
aimer où on ne va pas aimer coloré 6 bon
je trouve que ça fonctionne quand même
bien vous avez toutes vos applications
qui vont venir être logés ici vous avez
votre tiroir d'application de fou après
pas mal de possibilités de
personnalisation et tout ça fonctionne
bien évidemment sur un android 9 paille
après il ya notre pote est pas mal et
non des moindres c'est la partie photo
vous avez deux capteurs un capteur
principal la regarder j'aime bien là ce
petit détail qui fait ça me rappelle le
chiot mini 9 c'est assez sympa vous avez
une caméra principale de 16 mégapixels
qui ouvre à f
1.7 et un deuxième capteur de 5
mégapixels avec une ouverture de f 2.4
qui va être là pour le mode portrait est
à noter qu'à les banques vous avez une
caméra de 25 méga pixels qui ouvre à f
2.0 et bien croyez moi les photos sont
plutôt de bonne qualité à séoul est
assez bien je me le dire car vous avez
une caméra de sony qui marche
parfaitement bien derrière
et vous avez un traitement logiciel qui
est assez juste le rendu est bien que
vous avez beaucoup lumière en extérieur
je dirai ce que ça faire l'ensemble rue
des smartphones sur le marché celui là
elle maîtrise bien évidemment aussi
mais ce qui est intéressant c'est que le
traitement derrière logiciel est juste
et correct et bien on récupère du détail
et ça s'est vraiment bien et sur un
smartphone une fois de plus à ce prix là
il ya un beau travail qui est fait
premier cliché pris à l'extérieur on
retrouve
vraiment le détail sur les différentes
feuilles les couleurs sont résiste je
trouve pas particulièrement sur saturé
par rapport à ce qu'on peut retrouver en
réalité sur cette photo la dizaine là
dessus ça me paraît quand même pas mal
alors après on dirait que le point est
plus fait derrière que devant
bon ça c'est pas grand chose il
suffisait juste de déplacer le le petit
pan dont prendre l'image qu'ils donnent
sur celle là il ya du vrai détails sur
la fleur le point a vraiment été très
bien fait c'est vraiment hyper juste
vous sent plus un petit flou au niveau
de l'arrière plan je trouve que c'est
vraiment bien c'est vraiment des photos
qui sont vraiment de bonne facture
10ème là dessus le détail on voit les
petits s'il détails sur la feuille
les couleurs sont également assez juste
et là sur la caméra de ses deux filles
alors certes un petit peu alice et les
visages mais je trouve que ça lisse mais
ça une fois de plus c'est un traitement
qu'on trouve beaucoup au niveau des
smartphones chinois suis pas un très
très très grand fan mais il trouve que
malgré tout une fois de plus vu le
positionnement tarifaire
le rendu est assez correcte par contre
le gros défaut c'est sur la photo
transforme prochaine nuit là il a
absolument aucune lumière dans le studio
là où certains smartphones sortiront
celui-ci galère vraiment on voit rien on
devine des choses mais on doit
absolument rien autant dire que c'est
pas du tout son point fort la photo de
nuit le mode portrait fonctionne aussi
assez bien avec la performance derrière
du thym dragonne 710 ça des tours plutôt
bien il va avoir effectivement du mal
entre deux doigts ici mais ça c'est
normal on aura un dragon 850 5145 ça
marcherait bien là il a un peu de mal
avec le 710 mais ça une fois de plus ça
me paraît quand même relativement normal
on l'a donc un smartphone tout ce qui
est plus honnête un tarif tout ce qu'il
ya de plus honnête et welcome to read me
family si vous voulez faire partie de la
riche famille livre coûtera 199 euros
pour la version 4 gigas de ram 64 giga
de stockage et 249 euros pour la version
6 giga de ram sans le fusil gars du
stockage alors pour 50 euros de plus je
serais vous j'irais sur les versions 6
giga de ram mais en tout cas ce qu'on
voit et ce qui est vraiment très
impressionnant de la part de remy là
dessus c'est qu'arrivé avec le
smartphone à moins de 200 euros sur je
dirais la version d'entrée de gamme qui
déjà très très bien avec hun sen
dragonne 710 avec cette qualité de
fabrication et bien ils sont vraiment
forts elles sont vraiment très très
agressif et extrêmement bien placé donc
ça c'est un gros point fort on voit
vraiment l'agressivité des fabricants
chinois pour dire proposer des
smartphones toujours plus performants à
des tarifs toujours
mieux placé et là je vous le dis
clairement pour moi là dessus on a un
smartphone milieu de gamme un tarif
d'entrée de gamme effectivement il ya
des choses qui vont pas être parfaite
notamment au niveau de la photo vous
n'allez pas pouvoir faire énormément de
choses vous allez pouvoir faire des
photos en bonnes conditions de lumière
voilà la caméra à l'avant on fait
correct mais c'est pas le truc de plus
d'un certain petit peu trop alice et je
trouve que la partie colorimétrique sur
la caméra avant c'est parce qu'il ya le
mieux sans un smartphone que je trouve
de bonnes factures très bien positionné
si vous avez un budget entre 200 euros
pour acheter un smartphone de bonne
qualité
lauryn hill 3 je trouve vraiment cool de
le dire maintenant ce que vous en pensez
en bas en commentaire par rapport à son
concurrent principal le chien ont mis
leur et 27 comment nous trouver est ce
que vous trouvez mieux moins bien
intéressant oui non pas comment comment
vous le trouvez du point de vue du
design
a vous de me dire tout ça en bas en
commentaire et bien évidemment
continuera de parler de rides ni parce
que je pense que c'est une marque qui va
continuer à développer au salut en
proposant de nouveaux produits toujours
plus intéressant sur ce je vous embrasse
et je vous dis à demain ciao